وفقا لوزارة الخارجية الأمريكية ،
عقدت مناقشات صريحة ومثمرة
في بكين يوم الاثنين ، أحدث جهد
لمحاولة خفض درجة الحرارة بين
البلدين بعد
حادثين يحتمل أن يكونا خطرين متصلين بالجيش في
الأسابيع الأخيرة في نهاية الأسبوع في
مضيق تايوان ، يبدو أن سفينة حربية صينية
قطع بشكل خطير أمام
مدمرة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية والتي تجنبت
الاصطدام عن طريق خفض السرعة فجأة
الشهر الماضي ، اعترضت الطائرة المقاتلة الصينية
طائرة تجسس أمريكية في
المجال الجوي الدولي ، ويقول البيت الأبيض إن
المستوى المتزايد من
العدوانية العدوانية من قبل الجيش الصيني هو
المسؤول عن كل من المواجهات القريبة.
لن يمر وقت طويل قبل أن يتأذى شخص ما ،
وهذا هو مصدر القلق من
هذه الاعتراضات غير الآمنة وغير المهنية
التي يمكن أن تؤدي إلى
سوء فهم يمكن أن تؤدي إلى حسابات
خاطئة
أنواعًا من الحوادث التي تغذي العداء
تجاه الولايات المتحدة داخل الصين
وسيوضح سي إن إن سي أن ريبلي يشرح سبب ذلك.
شوارع في السماء والبحر
تصاعد الخطاب والولايات المتحدة تحذر من
خطر حقيقي من مواجهة عسكرية
قائمة متزايدة من تفجيرات الصين الأمريكية التي تغذي
المخاوف من المشاعر المعادية لأمريكا
في أوساط الجمهور الصيني.
يكشف التصور العام الغاضب عن تراجع الولايات المتحدة في استطلاع أجرته الصين مؤخرًا أن أكثر من
نصف الذين شملهم الاستطلاع لديهم انطباع
غير مواتٍ للغاية أو غير مواتٍ إلى حدٍ ما
عن الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية التي تواصل انتقاء الصين ، يقول هذا
الرجل في بكين إنه يشعر وكأن الولايات المتحدة
تتنمر على الصين
بطريقة أخرى.  وجهات نظره واضحة أنني لا
أحب الولايات المتحدة ، كل الأشياء السيئة في العالم
سببها استطلاعات الرأي الأمريكية تظهر أن
العديد من الأمريكيين لديهم وجهات نظر متشابهة حول
الصين حتى في مواجهة واشنطن المستقطبة ،
تحظى بكين بدعم نادر من الحزبين
من مضيق تايوان إلى
بحر الصين الجنوبي.  بالنسبة لسنغافورة ، يبدو أن الولايات المتحدة
والصين تقترب من
الصراع يوم السبت بسبب تصادم قريب في
مضيق تايوان ، اتهمت الولايات المتحدة
سفينة حربية صينية بقطع
مدمرة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية ، وتقول الولايات المتحدة إن كلتا السفينتين
اقتربتا من اندلاع الصراع على مسافة 150 ياردة أقل من 500 قدم.
أخرى ، اتخذت المدمرة الأمريكية
تدابير طارئة لتجنب الاصطدام
لقاء قريب وصفه وزير الدفاع الأمريكي
لويد أوستن بأنه خطير للغاية
أشعر بالقلق حيال في مرحلة ما لدي
حادث يمكن أن
يخرج عن نطاق السيطرة بسرعة كبيرة أوستن وهو يتحدث في
قمة الدفاع الآسيوية هذه  في سنغافورة ،
قال البنتاغون إن الصين رفضت
اجتماعاً مقترحاً مع
وزير دفاعها لي تشونغ فو
تفاعلهما الوحيد في هذه المصافحة القصيرة ، وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنه
لم يكن لديهما
تبادل موضوعي ، وكان الجنرال لي بحاجة إلى
قول الكثير بعد التصادم القريب الذي انتقد
مزاعم الولايات المتحدة بشأن السلام السلمي.  عبور
مضيق تايوان بسفينة
حربية كندية ليسوا هنا من أجل
المرور السلمي ، يقول إنهم موجودون هنا بسبب
التوترات الاستفزازية التي ارتفعت بالفعل قبل
أيام قليلة فوق
بحر الصين الجنوبي ، وهي حادثة في الجو التقطتها
الكاميرا لطائرة صينية قريبة بشكل خطير
لطائرة استطلاع أمريكية
تصفها الولايات المتحدة بأنها مناورة عدوانية لا داعي لها ،
وتقول الصين إنها كانت
تحمي سيادتها فقط متهمةً
الطائرة العسكرية الأمريكية
بالتدخل عمداً في منطقة التدريب الصينية ،
وقال المتحدث باسم الحكومة إنه يجب على الولايات المتحدة أن
توقف على الفور مثل هذه
الأعمال الخطيرة والاستفزازية التي
ترفضها واشنطن.  مطالبات إقليمية
على كل بحر الصين الجنوبي تقريبًا
تقول إن الولايات المتحدة ستستمر
في الطيران الشراعي وتعمل بأمان
ومسؤولية أينما يسمح القانون الدولي
بالتوترات.
بين رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن مكارثي
ورئيس تايوان وين ، ادعت الصين أيضًا
السيادة على
الديمقراطية المتمتعة بالحكم الذاتي ،
لم يتحكم حكامها الشيوعيون مطلقًا في إطلاق
جولتين من التدريبات العسكرية الضخمة
بالقرب من تايوان مما زاد من مخاوف الولايات المتحدة
من سوء تقدير عسكري محتمل له
عواقب وخيمة
على  يقول البيت الأبيض إن كبار
المسؤولين الأمريكيين طرحوا موضوع
التصادم القريب في اجتماع عقد في بكين يوم
الاثنين ، وحقيقة أن هناك
اجتماعًا يتحدث فيه الجانبان هو
بالتأكيد تطور مرحب به
لأولئك الذين يراقبون الوضع في هذا
الجزء من العالم.  لأن العداء
بين الولايات المتحدة والصين قد
تصاعد بشكل كبير في الأشهر الأخيرة
من تايوان وبحر الصين الجنوبي إلى
شراكة الصين العميقة مع
روسيا التي فكرت لفترة وجيزة عندما
التقى الرئيس بايدن والرئيس الحادي عشر في بالي في
نوفمبر الماضي والذي أخرجه
الجاسوس الصيني عن مساره.  أدى البالون إلى
عدم قدرة كلا الجانبين على إجراء
محادثات رفيعة المستوى ، وربما تشير حقيقة أن
هناك اجتماعًا في بكين إلى حدوث
تحول في ريبلي سي إن إن
تايبيه